yeah I mean I remember walking down the
stairs and seeing her and being like oh
wow oh wow
we became Facebook friends I'd told him
a couple weeks later I have a
performance of my own you should come
and I was like hell yeah I'm there then
I ended up going to her show on crutches
there are no seats so I have to stand
all sudden the curtains open and out
locks crystal and she's a clown the
tennis rackets so amazing because the
way that she fits her entire body
through the tennis racket and then takes
out a sword and she swallows a sword
which is crazy in itself as she
continued to perform I just wanted to
know more and more and more about her so
he was like have you ever been to
Mulholland Drive and we hung out there
until after the sunrise yeah oh yeah
8:30 9:00 in the morning I'm looking
into her eyes and she is still dressed
as a clown absolutely
when Jamaica hanging out and I'm a party
mo you're no hanging with boys so I go
to this market right all of a sudden I'm
looking to buy the mango and there's
this this angel I want you understand
what what I was going through when I saw
this beautiful woman imagine yourself
loving pizza you mean you love pizza and
all of a sudden this piece of shoulder
and it looks hot it's everything on it
that you love
I'm the pizzas you are the analogy of
the pizza you see one sec yeah yeah so I
went over there as hey how you doing my
name is Michael he wanted me to go back
with him to the resort which I decline
yeah you did and so then I get back to
LA and he asked me to go to Catalina
Island on the boat I got motion sickness
he lays down in my lap and then I see
this this man that went from this strong
guy to just adorable at that moment it
made me recognize that I had something
special here we went back to the office
group of us to keep the party going and
people started playing it was it was a
baseball it was like baseball and
cartwheels I think there was even like
the tiniest game of Red Rover one of our
co-workers sailed through the air and
head-butted this thermostat it was a
really deep cut and instantly it was
like party over so we decided we're
gonna go down to the drugstore and we
are going to get some carpet cleaner we
have to be really really careful when
you're making a move on your coworker
could you have to be able to walk it
back you know it feels like a little
like sort of ways to make personal
contact you could think of it any other
way so she had no idea that she was
being seduced I would say at the time it
was a surprise to me yeah you know
nothing brings two people together like
down on your hands and knees cleaning up
a blood stain I could be authentic I can
be Who I am
and that was very rare no and it's right
it's right
don't be afraid to go for it
oh okay